Let's revisit the grocery store report that we used
at the very beginning of these lessons for the big picture demo.
We've already gone through the process at
this stage of extracting and transforming our data,
we have three well-structured tables
right here or queries that will become table shortly,
and for us to transform them from queries to tables,
we're going to select, "Close and Apply".
This would also be the stage at which if we had
any additional intermediary queries like the ones that we
did to get the dates at the end of our date table process during our prior lesson,
we would right-click and select "Disable Load" so that they don't gum up
the space when we move into the data modeling and reporting stage.
But since we have all that we need exactly as is,
we'll go ahead and close and apply which brings us
to the model pane where we have our three tables at place.
Now before we get started,
I want to make sure that we label our date table as a date table.
The first thing I'm going to do is I'm going to take
the Store_Calendar date table and I'm going to explicitly market in the date table.
The way I'm going to do that is by going over to
the data pane and I'm going to select Marcus date table,
I'll select the relevant column which presses date.
Right here it has gone through the process of making
sure that we've satisfied the requirements of a date table,
so you can see it has validated successfully,
and that'll turn on the different functions when it comes to time,
intelligence, and everything else.
From here, all we're going to do is take the key columns and connect them together.
Now, the user interface will allow you to just drag and drop to connect them,
but you can also go to Manage Relationships to add them if you choose and
select "New" and here we'll go to the Store Calendar,
select the column that we want to connect,
and then I'm going to choose the sales fact table and the column I want to connect here.
It's identified that it's a one-to-many relationship,
one being coming from the store calendar,
many on the sales,
and it's identified a single filter.
We'll go through all of those in a little bit.
If I ever want to look at these again and see the details,
I just double-click and the data pops up.
Finally, on the reporting pain,
we have a number of options for being able to create visuals,
but also to create a range of measures.
So you recall the subtotal measure here.
It's defaulted as a Sum,
but I can always change it to Average, Min, Max, etc.
which we will go through in a little bit.
We have a filter pane that gives us options for either creating
additional filtering for the entire report or sections of it,
and you have the additional option to create filters both through quick measures,
which if we right-click,
"New Click Measure" you'd get a series of options that will allow you to
filter based on a category which functions as
a measure or explicitly create filters in a calculation.